usa today has just announced its women
of the year and assistant secretary of
health richard levine has made the list
you go girl this is one small step for a
man and one giant leap backward for
women
the message here in philadelphia in love
park is that trans rights are human
rights you have worth you have
tremendous worth just for who you are no
matter who you love no matter who you
are no matter what your gender identity
sexual orientation or anything else and
to be true to that
and then everything else will follow and
it highlights something which i truly
believe in which is the value of
diversity diversity is just so important
in our culture it's important for our
country for the world now say what you
will about mr levine
he certainly adds diversity to the list
of women of the year but his message
doesn't make a lot of sense
his message the whole headline of the
article in usa today is be true to
yourself
but transgenderism does precisely the
opposite of that it encourages people to
be dishonest with themselves to lie to
themselves and to everybody else to
pretend that reality is different than
it really is
mr levine may or may not be a nice guy
he might be a friendly neighbor he might
be a good cook i don't know
the only thing that i do know about
richard levine is that he is not true to
himself
our society is now so divorced from
truth
that
we call men women we call abortion
health care we call criminals victims
richard levine is one very confused man
but what's our excuse
i'm so glad you like that clip now
please please i implore you ring the
bell subscribe get the notifications for
every video we put out best thing you
can do is go over to apple podcasts or
stitcher or spotify or wherever you get
your podcasts and subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review if you wouldn't mind
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you